[Music]
jared starts us off in california this
hour hey jared what's up
hey how's it going better than i deserve
man how can i help
i'm glad to hear thanks for taking the
call
um so
my our little situation here is a
family's growing uh we have a three and
five-year-old my wife and i
and uh we just pretty much uh like to
move into a bigger home uh we're in our
first home that we purchased
and just need a bigger home bigger
backyard
um
well i would say it's more of a wand
than a need but i think you get it
so the question is
things that i've been kind of trying to
figure out
should we sell the current home
and take the equity and purchase a new
home
or
save up for two to three years and put
down five to ten percent
for the new home and rent out the
current home
or just work on paying off our current
home
as soon as possible roughly maybe five
six years
um and then save up for another home
to move into cool
what's your household income
household income is about 160.
current home is how many square feet
18.50 how many bedrooms
uh three and an office okay cool good
all right nice home
all right um
i don't have any problem with you i
don't know a would be my choice um what
do you think i mean sell sell it and buy
something else as long as when you do
that your payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage but that
move up that way you definitely don't
need to move out and keep a rental
because you're you know you're not
paying for it we don't believe in
rentals until you pay for them
got it
because we want you to have the margin
to do that um
but yeah i don't see anything wrong with
it as long as you can afford it you have
a strong income you keep it 15-year
under 25 of your income i think you're
fine but i mean there's also the great
feeling that would come with paying off
your current house does that is that a
big motivation for you getting
completely debt free to baby step seven
yes um
yeah i think what i struggle with
probably like most listeners is just uh
trying to
enjoy you know especially we have a
three and five-year-old so trying to
enjoy the next 10 years or so you know
um
and so i think paying off the home
we can do it and i like that idea for me
but i think that that would kind of
restrain the family a little bit um if
that makes sense um
well i like the idea okay
i'll disagree with that i don't mind you
moving up if you want to move up okay
and you
adequately are accurately quantified it
is a want and and it fits and and go
ahead and do a you know move up sell the
house and move up again as long as it's
a 15 year fixed and the payment's no
more the fourth now let me back up
though just as a statement to all of
america
the enjoyment of your 1800 square foot
home with two children in three bedrooms
and an office
is not about the square footage it's
about your attitude
because you're talking to a guy whose
parents raised
a three-year-old and a five-year-old i
would have been the five-year-old in a 1
000 square foot home and no one at our
house in those days ever talked about a
lack of enjoyment
it didn't come up in the 60s
okay so enjoyment is um your mindset and
so if you chose to enjoy that and as a
part of your family getting that that
smaller home paid off and owning it free
and clear faster
than you will the larger one uh that is
a an issue of contentment an issue of
perspective
and but the square footage does not
cause enjoyment
your brain does right and if anything i
feel like the higher payment potentially
and the longer trajectory to getting
debt free could actually
that could take some of your joy right
exactly like the more your mortgage is
the more you're going to have to work
and make sure you're able to pay that
mortgage and you're going to take a
longer time to be debt-free so it's like
i think once you have not a payment in
the world you're going to have even more
time with your kids which is really
exciting to me so that's not to pick on
you jared i i'm going to go with a if
i'm you okay i'm going to move sell the
house and move up but while you're doing
that i do want you and i want to just
take that moment to create a soapbox
because it's something we've been
talking about around here a lot with the
real estate market going crazy and you
know it went up 32
in 20. it went up 18 in 21 went up it's
gonna go up seven percent this year and
probably about five percent next year is
what it's looking like and so
you and i particularly among the ramsey
personalities have had this discussion
of
you know this idea that you're kind of
getting priced out of the market and my
pushback on that has been that the yes
there is a legitimate thing a
yes that's true some people are getting
priced out of the market no question
about it but some of getting priced out
of the market is this idea that
you know the the difference in a stat
the difference in the
average home in america today
is a 2800 square foot two bedroom with a
skylight a jacuzzi and granite
countertops
the average home in america in 1962 was
a thousand square foot one and a half
baths hollow core doors and for mica
countertops and there wasn't a skylight
and unless someone shot through the roof
and so uh you know that that didn't even
know what that was and so uh
you know again there's nothing wrong
with having better things we're not
against having nice things but when you
set that as the standard for quote
enjoyment or the standard for this is i
i
i can't afford a house could be because
you can't afford a house it could be
because your standard of of a minimum
is so much higher
than any other generation in history
if you're listening and so it's some of
both that's going on that's causing the
people to be in air quotes priced out of
the real estate market you and i've
talked about this a lot right yeah
there's a lot of pressure especially
among my generation to have the bigger
house to move up like he said it might
make him a little bit happier to have
more square footage and it's it's fine
if you can afford it but just make sure
that you can afford it that it doesn't
delay your other goals and that you can
be happy regardless of the size of house
yeah
and be careful of the language that you
use as to what your minimum is
right you know
well
yeah i could afford a house but it'd be
over there
over there
in that area
you know that kind of thing and so you
know in this county you can't you know
well you're right i mean when i was a
kid we knew where the rich people lived
and it wasn't where we were you know and
i knew we couldn't live over there but
we never really set that as a as the
minimum standard
of where we were going to be and we've
had this discussion a lot around the
office even because our offices ramsey
solutions are located in the wealthiest
county in tennessee in the 11th
wealthiest county in the nation
so this is a very affluent county that
we're sitting in so to live within five
miles of this office building where
we're broadcasting right now is freaking
expensive it's so expensive so i mean
it's out of control and so it's bringing
up with our own team members here this
same kind of discussion
but you know you can live over there
yeah it can work this is the ramsey show